ننتقل الى تركيا وتطورات الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوب شرق البلاد وتسبب بانهيار عدد من
المباني الوكاله الحكوميه التركيه لاداره
الكوارث قالت ان الزلزال كان بقوه سبعه
فاصله اربعه وضرب ناحيه
بازاجيك في محافظه كهرما مرعش جنوب شرق
تركيا مقاطع فيديو نشرت على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اظهرت عده مباني مدمره في عده
مناطق جنوب شرق البلاد افادت مصادر ايضا
بان الاولويه الان في تركيا هي للوصول الى
المحاصرين تحت الانقاض وزير الداخليه
التركيه
اهاب بالمواطنين لعدم استخدام الهواتف
وفتح الطرق لوصول سيارات الاسعاف والانقاذ
الى الان لا يوجد حصيله سوى الابلاغ عن
خمسه ضحايا وعدد غير محدد من الجرحى لكن
فرق الانقاذ الان تحاول الوصول الى
المحاصرين تحت المباني بعض الانباء تحدثت
عن ان هناك
34 مبنى سقط وان هناك عدد من المحاصرين
داخل هذه المباني وتحت الانقاض وايضا عدد
كبير من المباني القريبه من الحدود
التركيه شمال شمال شمال سوريا ايضا
سقطت